did apple fix the studio display's
biggest issue or did they make it worse
well today we will find out in the most
detailed webcam comparison that you will
find online with a bonus surprise i have
a couple different scenarios as far as
lighting multiple different macs we have
the lg 5k we have a macbook involved as
well and we have something called camo
that i think you're going to be really
shocked by now first in order to update
your studio display you actually have to
have the latest beta version of mac os
monterey so once that is updated and
installed you can then find the update
for the firmware of this display now you
got to download it and then it ends up
actually restarting your computer and
then installing it on the display
telling you not to unplug it and then
finally bam we have the latest version
which is
15.5 now here is the quality of the
studio display before the update it
looks pretty flat you could see that
there's not a ton of detail at the top
left we have a section that's blown out
completely looks really weird it kind of
gets better and then it gets worse again
then we have a lot of noise in both my
face and the shirt down there with that
this is a center stage camera so it's an
ultrawide that is cropped in but the
crop looks weird i have way too much
space above my head and then down below
where my body is it just cut way too
short so how bad does this actually look
well here is the lg 5k ultra fine
that looks pretty bad i mean we don't
have any noise issues but look how dark
i am now that's because this is a tough
situation it is a bright room but behind
me i have that window so the monitor
that everybody's comparing the studio
display to what you guys see in the side
by side it just does a way worse job i'd
much rather have the studio display now
before we see the firmware fix this is
what a 16-inch macbook pro looks like
the brand new one with the m1 max i did
prop it up on the box at the same angle
and i would say that other than the
noisy shirt and some noise in the face
the studio displays webcam before the
update does still look better my face
looks more natural uh overall i think
it's a more pleasing image instead of
the much smoother macbook and now let me
show you camo now if you guys saw i did
a video on how to up your macbook's
brightness up to a thousand this guy
that created this app he's actually a
friend of the guy who made that one it's
an indie company
and look how shockingly good this looks
this app actually allows you to connect
your phone an iphone or another phone to
your mac or your pc you can even connect
an ipad and it looks great and now let's
look at the side by side
my goodness that difference is huge my
face looks more natural a little bit
warm but we'll get to that the shirt
there's so much detail no noise at all
it looks fantastic and look at the blur
that is actually natural blur from my
iphone now they actually do have a
portrait mode that you can enable and
it's processed on your phone so it
doesn't take up cpu power so that's the
blur and i'll show you the app in a bit
but overall using your phone is way
better than any of these now we have the
update installed let's see what that
update looks like
so here you guys go
there is the update uh it definitely
looks a lot worse than the camo but in
general you'll notice how much lower the
framing is so apple actually went and
they cropped it in differently lowered
it this the monitor was set up exactly
the same and of course they added a lot
more contrast now there's a couple weak
things that are a little bit weird first
off there's actually too much contrast
my shirt is actually crushed at the
bottom right
and second there is no noise in my shirt
at all that's completely gone my shirt
it actually lost detail but my face
gained detail so this is a lot of
processing going on where they're adding
noise reduction in certain areas and
sharpening but not in other areas
overall though i would say that it does
look a lot better than it did before at
least in that scenario now i also tested
out the whole center stage feature which
i'll show you but let's take a look in
this room right here where we do have
some pretty good lighting but it is a
little bit darker right here is the shot
once again we have too much headroom but
actually doesn't look too bad once again
we see all that noise in the shirt in
the face but it's the colors look pretty
dang good
this is what the lg looks like right
here guys
way too crushed too much contrast uh the
colors maybe a little bit more natural
but probably too blue here's a shot from
my macbook we have no noise but all the
details kind of gone too looks kind of
waxy so personally i would take the
studio display before the update for
this and now let's see what apple's fix
does in this scenario so here you guys
go
wow that is a dramatic difference we
have a little more detail in the face
the noise is gone from the shirt but
look how dark everything is my hair and
my hoodie that i'm wearing right now
honestly i think it's just too dark and
i would say that i would rather have the
old firmware in this kind of a scenario
with controlled lighting because i'm
just way more visible other than that
extra headroom so overall i am a bit
mixed i don't know if they actually
fixed it or if they made it worse it
kind of depends on how your studio
display is set up but now let's take
another look at camo because i was just
shocked before and wow look at that
that is unbelievable that looks like i'm
looking through a window or i'm sitting
next to myself here shockingly good not
only the detail the lack of noise
contrast is perfect the colors are great
white balance is really really good
looking
man okay
let's look at it side by side with
apple's fixed firmware for the studio
display
oh
man there you go that is just a shocking
difference in every single possible way
not only does it look better we also
have some of that natural blur from the
larger sensor of the iphone and these
iphones just look amazing this is iphone
13
the sensor the processing all that's
done on camera and it's way better than
any webcam you can buy even webcams that
cost hundreds of dollars now of course
you can enable blur if you want it with
there's that portrait mode and then this
is kind of the effect that you get now
i'll show you how to get and set up camo
but first i want to show you guys the
difference in center stage previously
there's that image tons of noise
it would kind of frame you a little bit
weird and then you have a delay when
you're shifting sides or adjusting your
framing and afterwards we have the
quality difference it's framed a little
bit better and then it is quite
responsive when you're just moving
around and adjusting now i have a link
to camo down in the video description
below if you guys want to check it out
but it's super simple you can actually
use it for free there's a free version
and paid version but you just go to the
app store you download the camo app and
then once you launch it it'll tell you
and actually give you a link to be able
to set it up the camo studio on your
desktop and once you do you just plug
your phone into your computer and launch
the app that is it so look at that guys
look how good that looks i'm just
plugged in with the lightning cable that
came with my phone
um i'm a little high here because i
don't have a mount for it i literally
just used a piece of tape and i put it
down on top of the monitor uh camo they
recommend this 15 grip arm that you just
pop your phone onto and put in the
perfect position
uh i'll link that down in the
description as well look how good this
looks in the auto setting
now i do have the paid version and they
have different ways you can pay for it
look we can go and switch to an ultra
wide or you could change to the
telephoto oh jeez look at those pores
man so you have the option to change if
you want to the selfie camera
change the quality uh there's actually
even focus so if you have issues with
stuff going out of focus with your
webcam where it's back focused look at
this you can literally just adjust it
and set it manually and then it
literally will not pulse or change or
anything like that there's different
effects right now i have the camo logo
opened up and set up right there but you
can actually just remove it or you can
change to any logo you want if you want
to show up a logo you do hotkeys the
cool thing is also exposure so if say
you have some lights that are strobing a
lot of the colorful leds do you can just
go ahead and adjust your shutter speed
to get rid of that you can adjust your
iso if you want to of course we have
white balance flash if you want it so
here i'll turn the flash on i don't know
if you guys could see
literally i can adjust the brightness if
you're in a darker room you want to fill
in that is super cool of course your
contrast if it's a little too contrasty
bam you can change that so you can fix
the all your settings you can add a
little bit of sharpening if you want to
say you're a little bit too
warm looking let me go ahead and adjust
my hue a little bit bam we can just fix
that and i think they're actually going
to be supporting the studio camera as
well so if you don't like the way apple
fixed it you don't like all that extra
contrast they're going to be supporting
the internal camera so you can do all
these tweaks with that in a future
update so if you guys want to check this
out it's they're friends with the guy
who made the display 1000 brightness app
that is super cool
that we showed off go download it for
free use the free version get the paid
version if you want all the extra
features um and it's an easy way to use
the smartphone you already have to get
way better webcam quality
so you guys let me know how do you think
the studio display looks now compared to
before and compared to the macbook and
the lg what are your thoughts on it
click that circle above to subscribe if
you guys want to see more videos and to
help us reach your goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]